this question comes from Jesse in Texas
he visits Dave Ramsey dot-com to ask I'm
24 years old and our family had three
cars for the four of us last week I blew
the transmission taking a corner too
fast so the cars totaled I am paying my
parents the deductible and insurance
will cover the rest of the value of the
car my mom's been hounding me that
wrecking the car will lead them to
having to buy a car with payments but to
me it feels like they're blaming me for
them buying a $20,000 car when the wreck
when the car I wrecked was worth around
10,000 I'm just trying to decide how
responsible I should feel or what I
should be okay paying them and what sort
of boundaries I should create with him
about this should I buy my own car
answer to the last question first
yeah yes answer to the other question
you should feel a hundred percent of the
blame because you took the car to fit
you took the corner too fast and blew
the car out the cost of the car that
your parents are driving isn't the point
here the point here I broke somebody
something and I've got overs I've got
two as a part of being forgiven is
restoration I've got to make this right
I don't know Dave this is this question
I I don't like the heart of this
question if that makes sense you're
reading the am i reading into it wrong
no you're reading the sentence structure
and seeing stuff in there more than just
the detail yeah yeah so this this
question my mom's hounding me that
wrecking the car it should have only
been worth ten thousand they had a
twenty thousand dollar car all along I
don't know right had a they had a the
car he wrecked was worth around ten
they're wanting to buy okay okay okay
differences on them there you go that's
right there you go differences on mom
and dad you don't have to feel any blame
or shame for that portion
no but and so she can't say you forced
her to buy a twenty thousand dollar car
when she was formerly had a ten thousand
dollar car that's my car
go buy a car there were places this I'm
still trying to figure out how taking a
corner blows the transmission and totals
a ten thousand dollar car a seller he
rolled it to maybe I don't know either
okay so there's insurance
and mom and dad have a $10,000 car and
they need to get a $10,000 cars what I
would recommend them they're gonna get a
10 does another check and they should
just use that to buy that car however
that yeah there's a deductible right and
whatever the deductibles are you should
be responsible for that and you should
go get a separate car of your own which
will probably cause a couple of things
one is it will cause you to drive
differently
and the second thing it maybe maybe then
the second thing is that that then you
don't have all this interwoven stuff
with your parents with blaming and
shaming and you being responsible and
not feeling responsible and all those
kinds of things you are responsible for
causing the disruption in the family
with your recklessness and you are
responsible for any out-of-pocket money
that that costs them to replace the car
equivalent to what you were driving and
I I this points to a broader
conversation I had a conversation with
extraordinary Minister last night we
just spent some time together hanging
out and we were talking about the
foundations of forgiveness and he said
something profound that I think all of
us can listen to but this idea of
forgiveness is if you do something that
hurts somebody and you come and say hey
I'm sorry I want to make this right
you have to let the person who was hurt
speak into here's how we're gonna make
this right and I can't come to you say
hey I messed up and my expectation is
I'm gonna tell you how I'm gonna how I
can fix this because there's a there's a
bigger picture there now you're exactly
right Dave and I missed the sentence
here if mom and dad say well then I need
to get a $50,000 car here so you're
gonna cost us 40 grand and that's not
true that's not true and that's not
that's not if that's necessary for them
to be forgiving then you have a toxic
situation with them that's a different
thing but you should make whole any
damage you've caused and sometimes
holding this hurts yeah right yeah
and so I mean if you I'm gonna call her
other day that the friend wasn't
speaking to her because she borrowed a
bicycle that disappeared stolen remember
that right was you and me Wes right yeah
and we we never heard how much the
bicycle cost right give her five hundred
bucks but was it a $1,200 you know you
know advanced whatever mountain bike or
whatever you know I and so we don't know
did she leave her service so you need to
make them whole like and beyond that you
know a little bit maybe here there but
beyond that if they start to try to do
oh I need double-hole to feel okay then
that starts to be a problem their side
of the equation and you know the whole
forgiveness thing starts to unfold
sometimes it's unclear what hole is but
in this case it's very clear when that
goes all the way down to that bottom
question which I love the way you answer
that order if you have your own car as a
24 year old this isn't an issue yeah
not a thing changes everything yeah yeah
I accused you of driving better however
that has never been the case for me just
because I got my own car to never-never
once that it make me drive I don't know
I'm working on it thanks for the fix for
the the the question Jesse yeah
absolutely